[ANNOUNCEMENT]
JEFFREY TOOBIN: Hello, everyone. Should we
get started? Wait, there's someone coming
in.
Well, welcome. I am Jeffrey Toobin. I'm happy
to be the moderator today.
Today's meeting of the Council on Foreign
Relations is called "The Synthesis of Law
and Politics in the -- and the Evolution of
International Justice."
Please completely turn off, not -- vibrate
is not good enough. Please turn off your electronic
devices. This meeting is on the record, and
the next meeting of the council is for CFR
fellow Richard Betts and his new book, "American
Force: Dangers, Delusions, and Dilemmas in
National Security," on February 13th.
Our occasion today is mostly to celebrate
David's new book. David Scheffer is the Mayer
Brown/Robert A. Helman Professor of Law and
director of the Center for International Human
Rights at Northwestern Law School. He is the
former U.S. ambassador-at-large for war crimes
issues in the State Department in the second
term of President Clinton and is the author
of -- show the book; it's always important
to show the book -- "All the Missing Souls"
--
>>MR. : Buy the book.
>>TOOBIN: -- buy the book; even better -- "A
Personal History of the War Crimes Tribunal."
David was named one of the top global thinkers
of 2011 by Foreign Policy magazine. He was
recently named as the adviser to the secretary-general
on war crimes issues in Cambodia, because
his former jobs were not depressing enough.
(Laughter.)
John Bellinger is an adjunct senior fellow
at international and national security law
at the Council on Foreign Relations. He's
a partner at Arnold & Porter. And he was the
legal adviser in the State Department in the
Bush administration.
So, David, let's -- the book is basically
about your tenure as the ambassador-at-large
for war crimes issues. You were the first
person in that job. That position did not
exist before.
So today, looking back and looking forward,
is a war criminal at risk of prosecution today?
>>DAVID SCHEFFER: Oh, I think far more today
than in the past. I think everything's relative.
There will still be an enormous range of political
and military leaders who will escape the jaws
of justice, so there's no question about that.
But I think if you look at what has happened
in the last 17 years, beginning in 1993 and
reaching to the present day, I think we do
see the beginning of the end of official impunity.
We're certainly not there yet. But I think
the idea that political and military leaders
can actually plot genocide, crimes against
humanity or massive war crimes and assume
that there is some pass or exclusion from
any liability simply because of their official
status -- those days, I think, are starting
to come to an end. And we have a track record
now of a number of leaders who in fact have
faced justice since 1993, before these war
crimes tribunals.
>>TOOBIN: And we've had war crimes tribunals.
The International Court of -- the International
Criminal Court exists. What do you think has
been the most important thing in creating
a world where there is at least the possibility
of legal action against perpetrators of war
crimes?
>>SCHEFFER: Well, I think the most important
thing is that hopefully it will begin to influence
the character of certain policy-making. In
other words, if we can, over the generations
and over the decades, understand that these
courts -- and particularly the permanent International
Criminal Court does exist -- and that if one
steps over a particular line in terms of how
you conduct either state policy or rebel policy,
that you will subject yourself at least to
the scrutiny, if not the official investigation,
of a criminal court, if you in fact veer into
criminal conduct, I think that's a significant
step.
After World War II, we had a momentary experience
at Nuremberg and Tokyo with this, and it was
very dynamic and very pointed and very significant
at that time. But it faded, I think, from
our memory throughout the entire Cold War,
and I think it's a constructive step that
over the last 17 years we've started to resurrect
that but in a -- in a quite different way
and, I think, a more meaningful way internationally.
It's not precisely victor's justice. I think
oftentimes it probably can be viewed as the
justice of the powerful over the weak. I think
that's still of some significance in the system.
And the permanent International Criminal Court
is designed to, I think, try to even get away
from that formula to a more balanced approach
to justice.
But there are certain, you know, geopolitical
realities that obviously make that a very
qualified, you know, prediction.
>>TOOBIN: What has -- but I meant sort of
-- I mean, institutionally, what's worked
best? The regional tribunals --
>>SCHEFFER: Oh. Oh, I see --
>>TOOBIN: -- or the criminal court or what
institutions have been most successful?
>>SCHEFFER: Well, I suppose so far the verdict
on the International Criminal Court is out.
We don't even have a single conviction yet
or a judgment for the ICC.
But if you look at the work product of the
International Criminal Tribunal for the Former
Yugoslavia, for Rwanda, the special court
for Sierra Leone -- those three courts, I
suppose you could say, are regional courts.
They're -- all three of them are international
courts. And although each one of them had
particular difficulties and problems both
in their creation, in the early years of their
operation, I think at the end of the day you
have to conclude that they achieved their
primary objectives of bringing to justice
the leaders of atrocities in those regions
during particular periods of time. That limited
objective can be extremely useful and efficient
for the international system. The problem
of course is the cost and the political capital
that has to be expended every time you approach
one of these issues from a strictly regional
basis with a newly created regional court.
It's a very, very difficult process, which
is one of the reasons of course the ICC, the
International Criminal Court, was negotiated
in the 1990s, was to try to provide actually
some efficiency in the system. And we have
to still see whether that will bear true.
>>TOOBIN: One of the most interesting chapters
in your book is what you call American exceptionalism,
and much of what your book is about is the
intersection of American foreign policy with
whole issue of war crimes. I mean, without
telling the story of your whole book, what
is -- I think you have said that it had -- that
being American is both the best thing and
the worst thing about being involved in this
field. Describe what you mean by that.
>>SCHEFFER: Being the lead American negotiator
on these war crimes tribunals was a tremendously,
shall we say, influential and occasionally
quite powerful position to be in. It is -- and
many of you in this room have been negotiators
for the U.S. government, so you know exactly
what I'm talking about. You do bring the weight
of your most powerful nation in the world
into the room. And that is extremely significant.
You can change things. You can work compromises.
You can bring that influence to bear like
no other nation.
But at the same time, I was bringing in that
other sort of exceptional characteristic of
the United States, which is that we're a globally
deployed military power. Our military dwarfs
all other militaries. And so for -- it's particularly
for an issue such as this, where you're talking
about war crimes, crimes against humanity
and genocide, which so often involve the use
of military force and commanded military forces
in the field -- you can -- you can quickly
find yourself in a situation, as the United
States did in the 1990s, in these negotiations,
where exposing ourselves to this kind of liability,
particularly since it's highly sensitized
with our global military presence, becomes
a very, very difficult equation to work out
in the negotiating room.
I think I have one line in there where I say,
in terms of the ICC negotiations, instead
of being the slayer of impunity, I became
its champion at times, because I was seeking
a certain level of impunity for U.S. military
forces. And that became a very difficult equation
to negotiate, paradoxical and almost hypocritical
at times, and it can undermine and sap your
strength in the negotiating room.
Ultimately, it did. Ultimately, it did.
>>TOOBIN: Well, before we turn to John, if
we could just move the story forward a little
bit, which is, describe what you saw in the
Bush administration. What became of your work?
>>SCHEFFER: Well, on the one hand, on the
International Criminal Court ledger, I thought
it was a -- it was a very regressive period,
the first term of the Bush administration.
There was a sort of a de-signing of my signature
of the Rome Statute, to -- so to speak. And
-- yeah.
>>TOOBIN: Well, could you -- for those of
us who are not particularly well-versed in
that issue, describe -- just as a factual
matter, what is the American position with
regard to the International Criminal Court?
>>SCHEFFER: Ah, well, it depends on what year
you're asking. (Laughter.)
>>TOOBIN: Well --
>>SCHEFFER: But let me also say -- I can answer
the question, though.
>>TOOBIN: -- since the '90s --
>>SCHEFFER: I -- yeah, I can answer the question.
President Clinton publicly stated six times,
on the public record, that he wanted to see
a criminal -- an international criminal court
built, and he wanted it built by the end of
the 20th century. So guess what my instructions
were: Build the court.
So I was there to negotiate the actual building
of an international criminal court and to
have the United States as the supporting pillar
of that court. The question at the end of
the day and at Rome in 1998 was precisely
what kind of court with what kind of jurisdiction;
how would it be triggered, et cetera. All
of that became rather complicated.
But the hope for such a court remained within
the Clinton administration, and by the end
of December of 2000 I was in a position, at
the president's instruction, to actually sign
the Rome Statute and at least indicate that
we're there as a signatory. We said that we
still have a lot of work to do on this treaty,
because there were -- there were years of
supplemental negotiations still to take place.
And even President Clinton today is -- when
you look at what he has said since he was
in office to the -- to today, you know that
he still has great support for the creation
and the working of the International Criminal
Court.
As far as the United States is concerned,
however -- and I know John will, I think,
support me in this -- is that there's a -- not
only just a fractured view of whether the
United States should be in the International
Criminal Court, but a view of whether we should
be engaged at all with the work of the court.
And I think this is where I think there's
been great progress. Ever since 2005 when
we abstained on the referral of Darfur to
the ICC and in the second term of the Bush
administration, there were increasing steps
of informal cooperation and of communication
with the court.
And in recent years there's been a significant
amount of U.S. coordination and cooperation
with the court, even to the extent last October
of a hundred U.S. military servicemen being
deployed to Uganda to work with the Ugandan
military for the express purpose of tracking
and apprehending the indicted fugitives of
the Lord's Resistance Army, who need to stand
trial in The Hague. And I -- and that is -- that
is the United States using some of its own
military assets to achieve a very key objective
of the ICC.
>>TOOBIN: So let me just move to John, because
I don't want to neglect you completely. What
did you feel the Bush administration's attitude
towards war crimes tribunals was? What -- how
did you define yourselves sort of objectively
in the world and versus the Clinton administration?
>>BELLINGER: Yeah, well -- and let me take
that sort of in two pieces, because the -- there
are the ad hoc tribunals, which David mostly
talks about in his book before he gets to
the ICC, and then there's the International
Criminal Court, which is a different kettle
of fish. And let me say a word about each
of those.
I mean, first, I think almost everybody in
the room knows, if you know David -- I mean,
he really deserves tremendous credit for the
work on -- particularly on the ad hoc tribunals,
but also trying to pull together the whole
Rome Statute. And with respect to the ad hoc
tribunals, I think the Bush administration
really just continued that policy.
If there's one thing I really disagreed in
the book -- although I'd confess I've not
read all of it, but I did read page 417 -- (chuckles)
-- in which he said that he felt that the
Bush administration -- it has essentially
ignored the ad hoc tribunals. I actually would
invite David maybe to take back those words,
because I think it's really not true. We actually
built on what David had done, largely because
his former deputy, Pierre Prosper, then became
our war crimes prosecutor.
But we were tremendously supportive of the
three ad hoc tribunals, the ICTY for Yugoslavia,
Rwanda and the Special Court for Sierra Leone.
We poured millions of dollars, $300 million
into the ad hoc tribunals. We provided tremendous
diplomatic and operational and intelligence
support. I candidly think -- but I can't really
compare directly -- but Secretary Powell and
Secretary Rice were more supportive of these
tribunals and Pierre Prosper's and our efforts
maybe even than some of the work David had
behind him. I mean, they were out hauling
up world leaders, insisting that there be
cooperation with the -- with the ICTY, with
the ICTR, the Special Court for Sierra Leone.
Just to give you one example to make it concrete
of how these things actually work, to have
high-level political support, we knew Charles
Taylor was in -- was being essentially protected
in Nigeria. We were putting pressure on Obasanjo,
the president of Nigeria, to push him out
so that he could be brought before the Special
Court for Sierra Leone. Obasanjo desperately
wanted to have a meeting in the Oval Office,
which we basically agreed to because Nigeria
was a(n) ally. And then in the midst of all
of this, Charles Taylor sort of disappeared
from our clutches. And Secretary Rice then
made it very clear to Obasanjo that there
would be no Oval Office visit for him until
Charles Taylor reappeared. And magically,
Charles Taylor reappeared -- (laughter) -- and
was picked up and delivered to the Special
Court for Sierra Leone.
So the main point overall is that with respect
to the ad hoc tribunals, I think in the Bush
administration, I would say the policy was
essentially the same. I spent lots and lots
of hours in the Situation Room at the White
House working on ways to bring Milosevic and
Karadzic and Gotovina and Charles Taylor to
justice before these international tribunals.
Philosophically -- and I'll stop and sort
of go back here, and we'll get back to the
ICC in a minute -- you know, I do think that
there was probably more of a feeling in the
Bush administration that international justice
ought to be done locally and regionally where
possible, more reliance on nation-states than
the default norm being an international institution.
But with respect to these ad hoc tribunals,
where there really was no other way of -- the
administration, from Secretary Powell and
Rice to the president -- hugely supportive
of those three ad hocs.
I'll stop, and we can come back to the ICC
-- (inaudible) -- talk about that.
>>TOOBIN: Well, why don't you respond to --
>>SCHEFFER: To respond to -- I think we have
a misunderstanding, because I didn't actually
write that on page 417. (Laughter.) But that's
OK. I -- John, it's just fine.
I actually support so much of what John just
said. The only thing that I would -- on these
ad hocs that I would take a little bit of
exception with was I think there was a period
in 2001 when we took our eye off the ball
on trying to get the Special Court for Sierra
Leone moving, as well as the Extraordinary
Chambers in the Courts of Cambodia. But it's
just a tactic of -- I mean, it's just an issue
of tactics during that first year of the administration
when, obviously, there was so much on -- you
know, coming at you that was -- that had to
be dealt with.
The point I make on page 417 is that this
book concerns events that preceded the so-called
war on terror, but the exceptional phenomenon
of the Bush administration years is how little
impact either the court-building leadership
of the United States during the 1990s or the
growing jurisprudence of those tribunals had
on the strategists of the Bush era, meaning
the strategists for the so-called war on terror
and the impact that the jurisprudence of the
tribunal should have had on their understanding
of international law as it relates to issues
such as torture and interrogation techniques.
>>TOOBIN: Well, John, let me ask you about
that, because sort of the undercurrent -- and
David mentioned it a little bit -- is, you
know, how do we construct international institutions
that -- when we are the country that is sending
troops out into the world and, you know, our
leaders are -- you know, we're -- are we exposing
American soldiers? Are we exposing Secretary
Rumsfeld to criminal liability in a way that
we don't want? Or are we simply -- not avoiding
criminal responsibility for American leaders
who should have it? And it's a good segue
into the International Criminal Court, which
is a fascinating discussion that sort of spanned
both administrations.
I mean, you know, the -- sort of the sad thing
is that the whole idea of an international
criminal court was one that went way back
into the -- you know, the first Bush administration
or even earlier, and Republicans and Democrats
had historically supported the idea of an
international criminal court, and it's certainly
more efficient than having all of these various
ad hoc tribunals. And I think a Republican
Congress back in the 1980s had said we endorse
the idea of an international criminal court,
provided that it meets American standards
of due process and is fair.
And what happened, I think -- you know, David
was there, and so it's really more his story
-- was that it went off the rails at Rome
and the -- our military got so concerned that
the court would actually be used against them
that they tied David's hands so that, you
know, we had to be one of only seven countries
in the world that actually voted against the
Rome Statute.
And there has been that concern that even
though, you know, we would like -- and I think
the Republican Party even is sort of split
on this. I mean, there are some who support
the concept of international criminal justice
but are concerned as to how it is applied
to us. There are certainly others -- I would
put John Bolton, I think, in this camp -- that
just really don't like the idea of an international
judicial institution to begin with.
Let me then say what happened with the International
Criminal Court in the Bush administration,
because I find it kind of fascinating, in
that perceptions, I think, overtook reality.
There's certainly a perception that almost
everybody in this room knows -- and particularly
if you're in Europe -- that the Bush administration
sort of completely changed policy and pursued
an entirely new policy. I would say that's
not really true; that there was a tonal change,
which I concede. But on the last day, as Bush
-- or as David talks about in his book -- in
which the Rome Statute was open for signature,
President Clinton, having voted against the
statute, authorized David to sign, so we signed;
but at the same time, he stated that he would
not send the treaty to the Senate, and recommended
that his successor, who at that point was
known -- President Bush -- not send it to
the Senate -- so in other words, saying: We're
not going to become a party.
So he essentially tried to have it both ways,
which we diplomats often try to do to appeal
to different audiences. I would frankly say
that was sort of the diplomatic equivalent
of smoking without inhaling -- (laughter)
-- that, you know, we were going to sign,
but we were saying we would not send it to
the Senate.
What President Bush did, I think, candidly
-- although I recognize the huge concern and
problems that it caused in the world -- was
frankly a little bit more honest about it.
He then sent a two-line letter to the U.N.
that said: We're not going to become party.
That's -- there really was no unsigning; you
can't unsign a treaty. He simply said formally
what President Clinton had already said informally.
Now, you know, I concede -- and this caused
us big problems that I actually had to then
work on -- is that everybody, particularly
in Europe, felt that we were then trying to
-- out to kill the court, and that this unsigning
was the first step towards trying to throttle
the baby in the infancy. And coddle -- and
coupled with this very ICC -- very anti-ICC
piece of legislation, the American Service-Members'
Protection Act, it appeared that the Bush
administration was out to kill it.
Now, as David says in his book, what was interesting
about the ASPA, the American Service-Members'
Protection Act, which authorized the president
to invade The Hague to free any American who
was imprisoned there -- this was all blamed
on President Bush, as if he had personally
written all of this. We didn't write this
piece of legislation. We didn't want this
piece of legislation. I actually negotiated
to try to cut out a lot of it. The -- this
was written by Republicans in the House who
were concerned on behalf of our military about
the ICC.
And one of the funny little quirks of history,
(which I now know she wishes she didn't do
it ?) -- David mentions it in the book -- is
Hillary Clinton voted for the American Service-Members'
Protection Act, this very anti-ICC piece of
legislation that authorized the president
to invade The Hague. But it was all blamed
on President Bush.
>>TOOBIN: David, do you want to talk about
that?
>>SCHEFFER: Well, yes. (Laughter.)
I just want to state what I think is a clarification
here, and of course, I explain this at -- in
some detail in the book, that the dynamics
and the rationale of what happened on that
signing date of December 31st, 2000, where,
you know, the president only had three weeks
left in office at that point, so it's utterly
implausible that you would submit a treaty
of that character, which requires an enormous
amount of implementing legislation, to the
Senate within three weeks -- usually, the
State Department Legal Adviser's Office -- Conrad
(sp), you might want to confirm this, as well
as my colleague John -- that, you know, it
usually takes a considerable amount of time
before you turn a treaty around and submit
it.
But I don't want to rest my laurels on that
technical point. What the president was saying
-- and he said this very clearly in the statement
-- was: I'm not going to submit it to the
Senate; there are still issues that have to
be resolved; we have to meet those issues
in order to make it eligible for submission
for ratification.
So there were issues to be resolved and, of
course, they weren't going to be resolved
immediately. But we did feel that, as being
a signatory state -- in other words, it wasn't
a rejection of ultimately ratifying the treaty.
That's what was -- not what was being said.
It was a recognition that we still have issues
that need to be resolved; we think we can
do so in supplemental negotiations. And that
was supposed to be my job, if we had won the
White House for the next term under Al Gore,
but of course we hadn't. But we were --
>>BELLINGER: Exactly.
>>SCHEFFER: We were signaling to -- (laughter)
-- we were signaling to George W. Bush's administration:
Look, we have set this up to protect American
interests. They'll be best protected if we're
a signatory state with the credibility of
a signatory state to pursue those interests
in the next term. It was a gamble, granted,
and of course, it wasn't really picked up
by the next administration; but nonetheless,
it was there.
On the American Service-Members' Protection
Act, yes, a fair number of Democratic senators
did vote for it; a fair number did not; likewise
on the House side. But John is absolutely
right, you know, in 2002, this was a Jesse
Helms/Tom DeLay bill, and it was in 2000.
We beat it back in 2000; it was resurrected
in 2002 and it prevailed for a vote.
And the important thing for all of you to
understand about this law is that the punitive
measures of it have all been repealed by Congress
-- a Republican Congress -- because it's understood
that they're undercutting other interests
of the United States. The only real punitive
measure left is the one John mentioned, which
is the widest -- I'm sure I'll be corrected
when I say this -- but the widest grant of
war powers I've ever seen to the president
of the United States: He has prior approval
to invade The Netherlands, without coming
back to Congress. (Laughter.)
>>BELLINGER: They -- I've got to tell a quick
story on that one --
>>SCHEFFER: Yeah.
>>BELLINGER: -- which may be -- which may
be apocryphal, so someone can correct me,
but I -- the received wisdom in the White
House was that after the American Service-Members'
Protection Act and the "invade The Hague"
provision, the new Dutch ambassador came in
to present his credentials. And you know,
they always make small talk in the Oval Office.
And apparently, the Dutch ambassador was actually
fairly honest; said: You know, >>MR. President,
I've got to tell you candidly, there's great
concern in my country about this new bill
that you've just signed that authorizes you
to invade The Hague. And the president apparently
wrapped his arm around him and said: I wouldn't
worry about it. (Laughs, laughter.)
The -- let me say a word about the -- (inaudible)
-- term, though, because that does sort of
get to where we are. You know, candidly, because
of these perceptions that the Bush administration,
you know, was really trying to kill the court
and therefore didn't actually believe in international
justice or accountability at all -- despite,
as I've said, all of the support that we were
providing for the ad hoc tribunals and the
fact that we clearly shared the goal of the
International Criminal Court, we were simply
concerned about how it would be applied to
Americans, and that it might be applied to
Americans even though we weren't a party -- there
then became this perception in the second
term, that many people know here, that we
were really out to kill the court.
You know, that caused me -- and I had spent
my first term at the White House at the National
Security Council -- some angst, that the Bush
administration looked anti-international justice;
which is really the point of sort of what
we're talking about here. So I, at the end
of 2004, after we won the election, wrote
a transition paper for Secretary Rice; said:
We really need to correct the record here.
You know, we're not going to change policy
and become a member of the ICC -- that's even
where the Clinton administration was -- but
we need to correct the perception that we
can have common ground. And we worked then
very, very, very hard on that, and I think
were largely successful, as David had mentioned.
You know, the first thing we did was to agree
to the referral of the genocide in Sudan to
the ICC. I and the war crimes ambassadors
gave numerous speeches emphasizing that we
shared the goal of the International Criminal
Court. We offered to provide intelligence
to the prosecutor. We waived restrictions
on assistance to countries that had become
party to the ICC. And then, by the end of
the administration, we then took the very
unusual step to become, frankly, the biggest
defender of the court, when other countries
who had been supporters of it -- namely, France,
and then China, who had not been a supporter
-- wanted to defer the prosecution of Bashir
of Sudan under so-called Article 16 of the
Rome Statute that allows a deferral of a prosecution.
Secretary Rice (in/and ?) our administration
did not want to let Bashir off the hook, and
she made it clear that we would veto, in the
Security Council, any effort to defer that
prosecution. So, suddenly the Bush administration,
which had started in 2001 as appearing to
be anti-ICC, had actually become in many ways
its supporter.
So I guess I would say the overall message
of the second term was a more constructive,
pragmatic approach of peaceful coexistence
in which we emphasize that we still have deep
concerns about the court's application to
United States, but that we could work together
with it. So that was sort of where we left
the --
>>SCHEFFER: Two seconds. I strongly support
what John just said about that final phase
in particular. I actually got drawn in by
Ambassador Williamson at one point about this
whole issue of the Security Council being
pressured by the African Union to suspend
the Bashir indictment for a year at least.
And I can tell you that the Bush administration,
because it held so firm on that issue of not
suspending it, actually ultimately pulled
France and Britain along with it, and that
was the three-member, you know, group they
needed to really block it within the Security
Council.
>>TOOBIN: At this time I'd like to invite
members to join the conversation with their
questions. There are folks with microphones.
Please -- why don't we start here -- wait
for the microphone, speak directly into it,
stand, state your name and affiliation. Please
limit yourself to one question and keep it
concise to allow as many members as possible
to speak.
Got all that? OK.
>>QUESTIONER: I think so. Hi. My name is -- (inaudible).
I have just gotten back from Afghanistan with
the U.S. Institute of Peace. And my question
is, broadly -- this is a little bit outside
of your particular jurisdiction, but how do
you reconcile America's purported support
for accountability for war crimes and other
violations of international law with what
we've done in Iraq and Afghanistan and the
approach that has been -- you know, we cannot
have peace and justice?
>>TOOBIN: That's the better version of the
question I was trying to ask. (Laughter.)
>>SCHEFFER: Well, let me take that on, if
I may.
I will be the first to admit that when you
look very objectively at both Iraq and Afghanistan,
there are natural questions that arise about
-- particularly in the field of war crimes
-- as to the conduct not only of the American
military but the militaries of other countries,
where this issue has cropped up. There have
been a lot of court martials and a lot of
investigations of the conduct of American
soldiers in both theaters.
First -- and this is very short, but the first
point is this. I think if you empirically
look at the corpus of what the U.S. military
justice system has done to review American
conduct in Iraq and Afghanistan, I personally
find some of it lacking. I find some deep
difficulties in how we have judged ourselves
in the field. And that's a long story, but
I just think there are some difficulties there
and they were amplified last week with the
Haditha sentence that came down, the three-month
suspended sentence on the Haditha massacre
in Afghanistan. And I think all of that takes
much more scrutiny.
I will also point out that the ICC, the International
Criminal Court, has under preliminary examination
Afghanistan as a matter, a situation that
has been raised with the court. They've had
it under consideration for many years now.
There's been no prospect that it will rise
to the level of a formal investigation yet.
But I think it is important to recognize that
Afghanistan is a state party to the Rome Statute
and therefore it is ripe for investigation
if so merited.
And I have wondered myself whether the first
non-African situation that is taken up by
the international court may indeed one day
be Afghanistan. And that's not just the United
States, believe me. I think the primary group
there is the Taliban and what the Taliban
has been doing. But it obviously does involve
the United States military.
>>TOOBIN: John, do you want to address this
issue?
>>BELLINGER: Well, briefly, just so we can
get to other questions. I mean, I agree with
your point, which is that there is a view
around the rest of the world that the United
States feels that this is sort of for others
but not for us, and that makes our job promoting
international justice at the international
tribunal level more difficult. On the other
hand, these tribunals, like the International
Criminal Court, are supposed to be for the
most egregious and systematic crimes, you
know, because one American soldier, even if
he's done something which clearly is a war
crime, that really doesn't make that person
a good candidate for the International Criminal
Court.
It makes our nervous -- our military, on the
other hand, extremely nervous because frankly,
all of these individual incidents do get referred
to the International Criminal Court. Largely,
the prosecutor says, you know, that's really
not what we're here for; we're here for genocide,
mass, systematic war crimes. But then if there
then (ends up ?) somebody who essentially
looks like they're either just not getting
prosecuted at all or get six months or just
a couple of years for something that looks
truly horrible in Iraq or Afghanistan, like
Haditha, it then looks like we have a double
standard. But it takes some explaining for
us to -- (inaudible).
>>TOOBIN: Another question? Yes, sir, right
-- do you -- oh, yeah.
>>QUESTIONER: Conrad Harper. I'm a retired
member of Simpson Thatcher & Bartlett. I want
to the thank both David and --
>>MR. : And a former legal adviser.
>>QUESTIONER: Thank you -- for an excellent
series of statements. I want to ask you a
question that's terribly unfair, but it has
--
>>MR. : (Off mic) -- David?
>>QUESTIONER: (Laughs.) It has to do with
the title of this presentation; you know,
the evolution of international justice in
the context of the synthesis of law and politics.
The issue of our position on torture during
the last decade, it seemed to me, put us at
war with much of what we had said not only
internationally but by way of treaty and obligations
thereunder. And I wonder to what degree you
think politics and law are necessarily at
war as well in this area.
>>BELLINGER: That is a huge question. I suppose
that's probably more directed at me, Conrad,
although David can --
Q (?): I think it's safe to say it's directed
at you, yes. (Laughter.)
>>BELLINGER: -- David can wade in.
It's a huge question. You know, I think certainly
the debate about torture has hurt the United
States and has hurt our reputation and image
around the world. You know, I just don't see,
wherever you are on the spectrum about the
CIA program and interrogations and all of
those things, that you can't concede that.
Whether it was -- what the United States said
was justified, people can argue back and forth,
and you can argue whether the CIA program
was consistent with U.S. criminal law, which
required an intent requirement to cause severe
physical pain or suffering and whether it
was consistent with the Convention Against
Torture. And that's a debate that continues
to rage to this day.
But it certainly, in my view, at least, and
certainly when I was legal adviser and was
trying, in the second term of the Bush administration,
to promote a conception of international law,
of commitment to rule of law and international
justice, you know, the fact that, you know,
the United States was itself accused of torture
-- and I had to be the head of the U.S. delegation
presenting the U.S. report to the convention
-- to the Committee on Torture in 2006. That
was not one of my most enjoyable moments.
But, you know, these are things that we had
to do, was both to try to promote international
justice around the world while -- explain
the decisions that the U.S. government had
taken.
>>SCHEFFER: And I can just jump in, if I may,
from the 1990s and say that I think, Conrad,
one of the sort of politics-versus-justice
dilemmas we had back then was actually related,
of course, to the International Criminal Court
issue, where not only the Defense Department
but, quite frankly, the State Department and
the National Security Council and certainly
Capitol Hill, I think they were deeply concerned
at times that the freedom we have to develop
our foreign policy and to execute our foreign
policy would be unduly influenced by the introduction
of possible liability before the International
Criminal court. In other words, that that
legal liability would impinge upon effective
foreign policy-making.
And there was an argument that they wanted
to separate that and not expose our policymakers
on military policy as well as on foreign policy
to the influence of potential liability under
the International Criminal Court. I mean,
that's -- that was the argument at the time.
And I had to grapple with that quite a bit.
>>TOOBIN: Over there.
>>QUESTIONER: Jeff Laurenti with the Century
Foundation. During last fall's heated debate
at the U.N. about potential recognition of
the statehood of Palestine, the big bogeyman
that agitated the Israelis was the fear that
they would sign -- the Palestinians would
then sign, by virtue of statehood, the ICC
Rome Statute, and that then Israel would be
opened up to liability for all kinds of potential
charges. Was that always an exaggerated fantasy?
Or to what extent was that in fact a real
concern, a real risk of facing international
legal action with Palestinian ratification?
>>TOOBIN: David, do you want to take that?
>>SCHEFFER: Yeah. Thanks, Jeff, very much.
Well, let me just take you back for a moment.
In the 1990s, I worked extremely closely with
Alan Baker, on just a(n) almost weekly -- daily
basis, it seemed at times, in terms of our
approach to the Rome Statute, to the negotiations,
and then ultimately to the signing. You know,
the United States was the 138th nation to
sign the Rome Statute on December 31st, 2000;
Israel was the 139th. The Israeli ambassador
was standing right behind me because we were
sort of coordinating our moves towards that
table. And once he saw me sign it, then he
had authority from the state of Israel to
sign the treaty.
So we had a very -- and the back story in
Israel to the signing of the Rome Statute,
the little that I know of it, I think is also
fascinating: how Holocaust groups brought
considerable influence and pressure on the
government to actually step up to the plate
and recognize the importance of the International
Criminal Court as a follow-on, frankly, to
Nuremberg and the legacy of the Holocaust.
But I think in terms of the Palestinian statehood
issue, Jeff, I for years have been talking
to my friends in Israel and elsewhere that,
if there's one thing that the peace process
should incorporate -- and, frankly, one thing
that should stimulate some acceleration in
the peace process, given this reality -- it
is an understanding that is codified into
the arrangement, the peace agreement between
Israel and the Palestinian authorities that
sort of stabilizes the liability net of the
ICC, because you know that the Palestinians
-- I'm almost certain they will rush towards
signature and ratification of the Rome Statute
the first chance they get. And there are legal
scholars right now that say right now they
have the right to do it right now. I mean,
so we have to be cognizant of this.
But I think the arrangement between Israel
and Palestinian should be: Look, the peace
-- the peace agreement will have an agreement
between our two nations that the Palestinian
authorities will not bring to the ICC any
alleged atrocity crimes under the Rome Statute
that have occurred prior to the date of the
peace agreement. So we have a bilateral agreement
between our nations that the past will not
be brought before the ICC. In exchange for
that, we, Israel, you know, are going to move
this peace process forward, with all the other
conditions that have to be met, of course.
And -- but that does mean that Israel has
to accept the reality, Jeff, that in the future
there will be a Palestinian state that will
doubtless join the Rome Statute. And Israel
has to factor that into its future foreign
policy.
>>TOOBIN: Yes, sir. Will you wait for the
microphone?
>>QUESTIONER: Bill Luers. Congratulations.
>>SCHEFFER: Hi, Bill. This guy used to be
my boss. (Laughter.)
>>QUESTIONER: Yeah. (Chuckles.)
I want to confess, John, that I -- my first
effort to smoke pot, I couldn't -- (laughter)
-- I couldn't inhale, and I never got high
-- (laughter) -- and I have a witness here.
(Laughter.)
David, talk a bit about the contrast -- or
the conflict between trying to get a dictator/genocide-committer
out of office quickly, and the court's inhibition
to make that happen. There was -- there have
been cases in the past where we've been able
to get a Marcos out of the country without
-- and the impunity issue didn't arise, because
it was better to get him out. And there was
an effort, which I was involved with, to get
Gadhafi out quickly in -- right after things
began to come apart. There's -- I still believe
there was an opportunity to do that. But once
the court did its deed, it was -- became much
more difficult. Talk a bit about that. You
and I have talked about this in the past.
>>SCHEFFER: Sure.
>>TOOBIN: That's an interesting dilemma, yeah.
>>SCHEFFER: No, absolutely, and it's a classic
dilemma here of: Do you achieve peace and
stability by essentially enabling someone
who is responsible for atrocity crimes to
live in sanctuary someplace outside of the
scope of the law?
I think the last 17 years have been very transformational
on that issue. When I came into office in
my position in 1993 with the Clinton administration,
one of our first tasks was not only this issue
of the Yugoslav Tribunal, but we were actually
having crisis meetings on Haiti and what to
do about the situation in Haiti. And the proposal
on the table to ensure that General Cedras
could be flown ultimately to Panama and live
happily ever after on the shores of Panama
was a pretty noncontroversial proposal. I
mean, there weren't people questioning: Well,
should he be brought to justice? It was a
-- it was a live option on the table. And
ultimately, in 1994, guess what? General Cedras
was flown to Panama, and lives happily ever
after, despite calls in Panama for his accountability
-- and I think they're legitimate calls; it's
just that he's now in a sanctuary.
My view is this. We have actually passed a
transformational moment where, by the commission
of atrocity crimes, the leadership that is
responsible for it simply does not get a free
pass. Now, that's a -- that's a generational
transformational moment in history, where
you cannot any longer presume that if someone
is responsible for the deaths of tens of thousands
-- hundreds of thousands of people, you're
going to arrange it so that that individual
never faces justice for it.
Now, I say that perfectly realizing that we're
going to have situations where deals are going
to be cut. And I think even with Gadhafi,
I was, you know, publicly, on CNN -- where
I could only speak, because they were asking
for it -- but, you know, I was saying on CNN:
Look, you -- Gadhafi has not been indicted
yet; he has every opportunity now to cut a
deal and to find a sanctuary; and quite frankly,
great, do it; get out of there; find your
sanctuary; and the law may not be able to
reach you in that sanctuary. It doesn't mean
the law's wrong; it doesn't mean that Ocampo
will not indict you. He may indict you. But
you'll be in your sanctuary, even if he does.
He did not seize that opportunity. He had
a clear opportunity.
So my view is, look, you know, we're not -- we're
not dumb about this. We're not going to wait
forever. If you wait until you're actually
indicted and then you say, oh, please, give
me my sanctuary now, guess what? I think we've
reached a stage where it's too late to give
you that sanctuary.
>>TOOBIN: This is obviously an intense moral
and political dilemma of, you know: Do you
give someone a pass to get them out of office?
Who decides that? Who's in charge?
>>SCHEFFER: Well, John, I want you to answer
this, but -- (laughter) -- I would -- I would
just say that I have logically somehow drawn
this line in my mind where: You're not indicted
yet, so talk to us. What's the deal? Where
are you going? But the moment that you actually
get indicted, that changes the whole -- the
whole picture.
And it doesn't mean that you're avoiding international
justice; international justice will still
try to pursue you. But I'm not saying that
for purposes of actually achieving peace and
stability in that country -- if the individual
is not yet indicted, it's perfectly fair to
be talking to him and trying to determine
how do we resolve this situation for the betterment
of the populace which is under siege.
>>BELLINGER: This gets actually into a very
interesting point about the independence of
the ICC prosecutor. And I think, as people
may know, one of the real concerns about -- that
the United States had was that the ICC prosecutor
is completely independent and really beholden
to no one.
One of the concerns in, frankly, both administrations
had been -- David would have been there with
respect to President Clinton -- was, gee,
if you liked our independent prosecutors in
the United States -- who, of course, had gone
after President Clinton -- you know, look
what worldwide independent prosecutors can
be like.
>>SCHEFFER: Well, I made that argument, you
know. (Chuckles.)
>>BELLINGER: And the one problem in this is
that the ICC prosecutor may not, in preparing
an indictment, necessarily be talking to the
rest of the countries in the world or to the
Security Council. If the person's smart, they
really ought to be doing that.
But I remember when I actually raised this
in Europe at one point, is -- you know, you're
not going to want the prosecutor to be indicting
a world leader while all the rest of the countries
or the secretary-general or a small group
of them are working to try to get that person
out, and out pops a(n) indictment that undermines
everything.
And at least the way the Rome Statute is set
up, and the way many of the countries in the
world want it to work is, they don't want
the ICC prosecutor to be engaged in a political
balancing. This is all such a pure view of
has a particular individual committed a war
crime that I'm not going to talk to the secretary-general
and say, is it OK if I indict this person
tomorrow, or are you about to actually move
him somewhere else?
>>SCHEFFER: And I would just jump in very
quickly to say, on Libya, of course, there
was a distinction; it was the Security Council
referral of this whole matter --
>>BELLINGER: Right.
>>SCHEFFER: -- to the ICC. So the prosecutor
is sitting there with the Security Council
saying, please investigate and, if merited,
indict. So it's a slightly different dynamic.
The prosecutor is moving forward with a Security
Council mandate.
>>TOOBIN: Can we talk about Libya for a minute,
or will you take another question?
>>BELLINGER: You know, talk about Libya quickly
-- quickly about Libya. Well, David writes
600-page books; I write 750-word op-eds.
And I wrote an op-ed -- Gadhafi, of course,
is no longer going to go before the ICC, but
there are two other people who were indicted
by the ICC prosecutor: Seif al-Gadhafi, Gadhafi's
son, and his intelligence chief, Senoussi,
who have been captured and are now alive in
Libya. And there is essentially a tug of war
going on right now between the -- at least
the -- some in the international community
and the Libyans as to where they ought to
be tried.
I think Prosecutor Ocampo has said he's fine
with having them prosecuted in Libya. But
there are others who say that there is not
a sufficiently well-developed judicial system
in Libya, it would be unfair to allow them
to be tried there, it wouldn't be real justice,
and they therefore must be tried before the
International Criminal Court, and Libya has
to turn them over to the International Criminal
Court.
>>TOOBIN: What's your view?
>>BELLINGER: Well, what I said in the op-ed
is that if the Libyans want to try them, the
-- we need to defer to their desire to do
that. The International Criminal Court is
a complementary court to complement a national
system. If we think there's a problem about
fairness, which I think there certainly is,
the answer is not to paternalistically say,
well, we'll take these people away from you;
we'll handle it. It's, on my view, to help
the Libyans to do it right, not only to ensure
that they have fair trials in the first instance,
but ultimately to develop the rule of law
in Libya over the longer term, to develop
those institutions.
>>TOOBIN: What do you think about those -- (inaudible)?
>>SCHEFFER: I would -- I'd just respectfully
disagree. Libya has been referred by the Security
Council to the ICC. And it may be that the
prosecutor indeed is negotiating this issue
with Libyan authorities. I don't know the
details of those negotiations, but I think
he's probably trying to draw some very clear
lines of -- you know, demonstrate to me that
you in fact can have a credible trial with
due process, security, everything else that
-- I mean, for some reason, the Security Council
referred Libya to the ICC, so there is a premise
there --
>>BELLINGER: Why should they have to demonstrate
that? I mean, it's their country, David.
>>SCHEFFER: Because --
>>BELLINGER: Why shouldn't they be able to
prosecute their nationals in their country?
>>SCHEFFER: Because the court is seized with
this situation, and it's seized under its
statute by the Security Council. So I'm looking
at this from the equity of the United Nations,
the Security Council, the equity of the International
Criminal Court, and not simply the preferences
of the Libyan government. This is already
within the jurisdiction of that court, so
I'm respecting that jurisdiction.
>>BELLINGER: But the Rome Statute is a complementary
system intended to complement --
>>SCHEFFER: Right. And that --
>>BELLINGER: -- the national justice system.
>>SCHEFFER: And that is a process. It is not
a conclusion. It is a process that has to
reach a determination as to whether or not
the Libyan courts are, in fact, capable and
willing to prosecute these two individuals
in a manner that holds up under the requirements
of the Rome Statute, quite frankly. So --
>>BELLINGER: But shouldn't the answer then
be -- (inaudible) -- right?
>>SCHEFFER: There is no automatic answer that
the Libyans automatically get them. It's a
process that has to be determined. And quite
frankly, I am of the view that I'd be interested
in the views of the Security Council as to
whether or not they are completely delegating
to Libya the prosecution of individuals that
a year ago they were extremely interested
in the International Criminal Court investigating
and prosecuting.
>>TOOBIN: Why don't we have one more question
from the audience? And then I have a question.
Yes, sir. Right here.
>>BELLINGER: You told me we were not supposed
to agree with you -- (inaudible).
>>TOOBIN: I've been -- thank you for following
my directions. Please, stand up.
>>QUESTIONER: Jim Raymond, International Institute
for Legal Writing and Reasoning. I wondered
if the situation in Libya doesn't have a precedent
in Rwanda, where the Rwandan courts wanted
to try these genocidaires, and the United
Nations said, no, no, no, wait; you got to
develop your courts first and prove to us
that you're capable of doing it according
to international standards. And so how do
you feel about the way that was handled? Was
it a good precedent for what we are doing
and should do in Libya?
>>SCHEFFER: Well, that issue's -- really came
to a fore within the last four years or so
when the Rwandan government really did try
to make a case for taking a number of these
cases off the hands of the tribunal. And initially,
they failed in convincing the judges of the
Rwanda tribunal to transfer the cases to Rwandan
courts because of certain issues, which really,
at the end of the day, proved to be very narrow
issues in Rwanda, but still of some importance
to the tribunal in terms of the existence
of those situations.
Just last December, just a couple of -- frankly,
a month ago, there is -- the appeals chamber
of the Rwanda tribunal has approved the transfer
of a case to Rwandan courts. So we do now
finally have it happening. There has been
a standard met that has satisfied the appeals
judges of the Rwanda tribunal, as well as
the trial court judges, actually. I think
the appeals judge was -- they were upholding
the trial chamber determination on this. So
it finally did happen.
>>TOOBIN: Council events end promptly, so
I -- we're not quite done. I -- just one question
that occurred to me several times in reading
your book. And I apologize; it's not as high-minded
as many of these issues. I mean, you were
dealing with the most unspeakable tragedies.
You were going to places, seeing dead bodies
everywhere. Like -- how did you deal with
that? What was it like?
>>SCHEFFER: Well, as I write in the book,
it certainly creates a certain frame of mind
about how you view the importance, I think,
of this work. And that is -- that is heightened,
which is why I'm still engaged in it. And
I was -- I was actually, you know, willing,
recognizing the difficulties, to jump back
into the Cambodian situation, because I think
it's extremely important that the deaths of
1.7 million Cambodians in the 1970s be answered
for in some credible process.
But in dealing with it emotionally, I will
tell you that after your second or third or
fourth mass grave or atrocity site, you can
actually start to get somewhat used to it;
I mean, understand how many humanitarian workers,
medical workers and even peacekeepers actually
start to get used to that. Of course, soldiers
do. But it is something you can -- you can
-- you can -- you can walk into and deal with.
But I could never get used to seeing children
in this -- in this situation. It simply wasn't
tolerable. And it wrecked -- it wrecked me
every time I saw it.
>>TOOBIN: Thank you all for coming.